people and folks who operate work and
run the business
in hollywood if you're watching get
yourself three pipes a basic t-joint
three end caps a couple of screws couple
of washers and a basic weight on the
bottom you could have yourself
a pretty cheap pretty effective
steadicam now that you know how to do it
can we please
stop with the shaky cam action sequences
i thought we were done with this
[Music]
so snake eyes is a nicolas cage movie
from the 90s which is why they had to
call this snake eyes gi joe origins
which makes sense because it's
completely worthy of a movie with
origins in the title henry golding plays
snake eyes he saves the life of a
character played by andrew koji which
i mean if you saw the trailer you know
who he is i mean i suppose a lot anyhow
i'll get to that in a second
you know what this is going to be
spoiler free until after i give my
rating then after i give my rating i'm
going to dabble into a couple of
spoilers
usually i do a spoiler-free review
separate video as a spoiler video but
i don't feel like it i don't want to the
entire time i'd be spending time doing a
snake-eye spoiler video i'd be like
why aren't i talking about dune right
now should be talking about the dune
trailer i don't think i'll have time to
talk about the dune trailer this weekend
but
that's my point that's why i'm not going
to do a spoiler video for snake eyes the
point is snake eyes is on a revenge hunt
and then andrew koji's character is like
hey
welcome to my family welcome to my clan
we welcome you in because we're nice
which makes one of them because this
entire time i'm like
so snake eyes is a dick that's fair i
mean i didn't see it coming i can say
that and credit where credit's due henry
golding was
good in the movie i've seen this happen
a lot lately movies are something i find
it sloppy or the script's kind of messy
or the characters suck but the actors do
a great job
given the script and content that they
have i mean it's one of those scenarios
which makes me even more depressed about
it you have these great actors bringing
it and they could have totally crushed
it
in a snake eyes movie that was you know
better or did the character justice at
all or a movie i would
watch again but that's what you see with
henry golding and andrew cogen in this
movie you're like oh i see what could
have
been damn it does the movie feel too
long absolutely and yes it does in fact
the whole
beginning scene with his father getting
killed and little kid snake eyes and he
was like oh vengeance after that's done
the very next scene is he's cage
fighting and i was like
this movie should have started out here
with him cage fighting maybe you can
sprinkle the father revenge tale into it
you start getting glimpses of that
maybe you don't even need the father
revenge tale at all as for the action
sequences i mean there are a couple
scenes of action sequences and again it
does that thing that movies do now where
everybody is completely invincible
sometimes they take damage
after they take damage it's like they
never took damage in the very next scene
it's like hey where's that
sword stabbing you got all right i guess
it's fine now between that and the
characters ridiculously flipping around
and being completely immortal and yes
like i said before some of the shaky
camps some of these
fights i'm like dude why are you cutting
martial arts movies and martial arts
fights
are most entertaining when you just have
it on the two actors the two characters
and they're just going at it you're like
dude this is uncut this is amazing maybe
there's a cut here and there but it
doesn't feel like it compromises the
action scene this movie did the thing
like all right we need to make it more
intense
or here we go yeah shaky cam there's
even a scene where scarlet's
walking not an action scene it's just
like the person with the camera was like
yeah we got scarlett it's like why
is it shaky cam she's just walking
dude really this movie doesn't feel like
a snake eyes movie and that's not just
because he
gears up in the snake eyes suit in the
last shot of the movie
i don't care about that you know it's a
snake eyes origin movie he doesn't need
to be snake eyes
for the movie or half the movie it would
have been better served
if he had earned the snake eyes suit at
all and yes earn the snake eye suit
while going into the third act so in the
third act he's actually snake eyes that
would have been better that said a snake
eyes origin movie with him not having
the snake eye suit
that's not what bothers me what bothers
me is the fact that there's no real
reason for him to get the snake eye suit
other than hey
he's snake guys of course he has two
which adds to the feeling that this
movie wasn't a snake eyes movie it was
some script
with some other story with other
characters and the studio was like i
don't know it feels kind of generic
but let's put g.i joe characters in it
so it'll be a generic movie
but with some gi joe characters boom
that's how we do it here in la la land
is how we do it in hollywood well i
can't say they're wrong there
if that was their thought also they have
to explain how snake eyes got his name
which
doesn't make any real sense i mean it
makes more sense that han solo is named
solo
than snake eyes snake eyes take that as
you will anyhow as a non-gi joe
non-snake eyes movie the movie was just
kind of
long-winded boring the movie feels like
a generic romp where the lead becomes
a ninja hero but he doesn't earn it and
he starts the movie out as an unlikable
[ __ ] and ends it as
pretty much an unlikable [ __ ] as a
snake eyes movie
it never felt like snake eyes on screen
i'm just not gonna remember this movie
in t
minus one day yep already forgot it's
all right with the spoilers here just a
couple of spoilers not gonna go
play-by-play but you know how it is
i just got to talk about a couple first
off gotta address the fact that the
trailer ruins not one but
two endings in this movie it's like they
were like all right let's show the last
shot of the movie in the trailer yes sir
technically speaking that's not the last
shot of the movie there is a mid credit
scene as well
all right well we'll show that in the
trailer too
i mean why did they do that the snake
eyes suit i can almost understand
because like people need to see him in
the snake eyes outfit
to make that connection but the storm
shadow thing being in the trailer
when it was a mid-credit scene no pass
yeah i ended this movie going alright so
snake eyes is a complete
unlikable dick and storm shadow is
absolutely justified in hating his guts
that's how i ended the movie and i keep
saying snake eyes dick without
explaining why he's a dick he's a dick
because
he gets taken into this place into this
clan by storm shadow
and he's like oh thanks man storm
shadow's like my home is your home
and he's like thanks man appreciate the
hospitality what you don't know is i'm
actually here as a spy to try to find
this magical rock that you have
and i'm gonna hand it over to some super
bad guy in the entire movie that's
that's his
purpose that's what he's there for he's
there to get this magical rock for a bad
guy
grenady's doing this for cobra because
cobra knows where the guy who killed
snake eyes father is but at a point you
know you gotta go
the ends don't justify the means and
snake eyes decides that
good for him very late in the movie he's
like oh
so they're gonna totally ransack this
town and vaporize people who are really
nice to me
maybe i should help the stone that gives
you the power of
vaporization which really reminded me of
fan four stick when doom was walking
around just melting people's brains or
whatever he was doing reminded me of
that this snake eyes movie it
swung too hard into the realm of magic i
mean gi joe i'm not supposed to take it
too seriously but when you go from
martial arts training stealth
stealth test take the bull from my hand
without spilling a drop of water it's a
stone that vaporizes people with thought
you know it's it's a little hard to
swallow so that's when snake eyes
actually turns back and goes i think i
made a mistake maybe i should help them
out because they're really nice to me
and i think they're all going to die now
but at that point
every time that dude had the stone and
just vaporize people i was like that's
blood on snake eyes hand
that's his fault too that's his fault
too and so storm shadow in order
to protect his home gets the stone and
tries to vaporize the bad guy who was
vaporizing people
and then it was like no you can't do
that
shame on you you cannot be the leader of
this place and he's like
what and he gets really pissed and
leaves but in the end it all comes down
to
yeah he blames snake eyes for all this
and it is snake eyes fault
it is to be clear a hero's arc where the
hero starts out as someone who's not a
hero and becomes
a hero i love an arc like that but this
movie didn't do it well it just felt off
not only the fact that
snake eyes doesn't seem to give a [ __ ]
that people were vaporized and it is his
fault
is that the people of that clan the
family of the people who were vaporized
also don't seem to give a [ __ ] that it's
snake eyes fault maybe that's what i
don't like about this that storm shadow
is this
tragic character and i actually do like
that they did that but storm shadow
totally gets the shaft and snake eyes
just gets let off the hook and it's all
just
fine it's like storm shadow you use that
stone to protect the people you know and
love
no that cannot stand you can no longer
lead this clan
snake eyes you actually gave the stone
to the bad guy resulting in the
vaporization of people we know and love
here here's a sweet ninja outfit
sorry for your trouble yeah i'm going to
be lamenting their deaths i'm glad you
don't act like you give any sort of [ __ ]
but hey take the awesome ninja stuff do
you have a vow of silence
no is your face burned no your vocal
cords cut
no oh so you can talk in the next movie
which i he can
in the next movie he fully has the
capability to take the helmet off and be
like hey
i'm still pretty where's storm shadow
there's no logistical reason he can't do
that
it just doesn't feel like snake eyes by
the end but storm shadow being a
sympathetic character who i
absolutely get where he's coming from i
enjoyed that but it shouldn't have been
done
at the expense of snake eyes you know
you can do that not at the expense of
the hero
you can just have a hero turn up being a
hero
and have the sympathetic villain still
be sympathetic
that's just complex writing actually
give the hero hero's arc don't just make
him a
spying backstabbing [ __ ] to people
who were nice to him and then
just say he was redeemed because he got
the snake eyes outfit for no real reason
whatsoever all right so snake eyes have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you